il ya un mythe tenace c'est celui qui
fait de la demie pomme le beau sain mais
en fait les seins des femmes ce sont des
poires des pamplemousses des cerises des
abricots et même des légumes pourquoi
pas des aubergines ya des saints en
forme d'ogive par exemple bref les seins
des femmes sont très divers et il n'a
que peu finalement qui arbore la demie
pomme idéal
[Musique]
le problème c'est qu'on ne voit pas
cette diversité des seins des femmes
dans l'espace public c'est toujours et
encore
l'idéal de la demie pomme qui
représentait sur les affiches dans les
publicités etc
donc on n'a même pas l'idée que les
seins des femmes sont si différents et
si divers tout simplement parce qu'on ne
les représentent pas dans leur diversité
le paradoxe est que si les singes ont un
rôle dans la vie amoureuse et sexuelle
dans ses débuts dans ces préliminaires
en quelque sorte puisqu'ils servent
d'appât d'attrait en quelque sorte
eh bien ils disparaissent ou quasiment
dans la relation sexuelle c'est en tout
cas ce qu'on racontait les femmes que
j'ai rencontrées il ya très peu d'hommes
qui prennent soin des saints une fois
que la relation est engagée si je puis
dire
ils ont été vaguement caresser un peu
titillé et puis ils sont complètement
oubliés
or les seins des femmes sont vraiment un
lieu de plaisir possible et même le lieu
d'un orgasme possible pour celles qui
ont la chance d'être sollicité comme il
faut est ce que j'ai pu observer dans
cette histoire c'est que les lesbiennes
et est de ce point de vue là avantages
et parce que dans la relation sexuelle
lesbienne c'est le corps dans son
entièreté qui étant envisagée est bien
souvent cela donne la possibilité aux
d'explorer en quelque sorte la
sensualité associé au sein
il y à cette idée est qu après une
grossesse et un allaitement les seins
des femmes se vident de leur substance
et deviennent en quelque sorte des gants
de toilette c'est tout à fait faux il ya
des femmes pour lesquelles c'est
absolument le contraire c'est-à-dire
qu'elle prenne une taille de saint après
leur allaitement
parce que ce que l'on ne sait pas c'est
que les seins des femmes sont infiniment
changeant qui ne sont en quelque sorte à
jamais les mêmes et que ces
modifications qui ont lieu tout au cours
de la vie mais aussi à l'échelle même
d'un mois eh bien à fond que leurs seins
peuvent être plus ou moins gros plus ou
moins rond selon les circonstances de la
vie l'une des femmes que j'ai
rencontrées pour mon enquête et est très
heureuse durant sa grossesse parce que
c'est ça avait grossi et elle était tout
aussi heureuse à l'issue l'allaitement
parce que ses seins sont restés un peu
plus gros qu'auparavant elle avait donc
gagner une taille de soutien gorge
l'idée selon laquelle quand les saints
ne sont pas soutenues par un soutien
gorge
eh bien ils s'affaisserait davantage
fosses puisqu'on sait que les ligaments
de cooper qui sont les suspenseurs
naturel dessin se tonifient lorsqu'ils
ne sont pas soutenus c'est à dire qu'ils
font leur travail quand il n'y a pas de
soutien gorge alors qu'ils abandonnent
en quelque sorte quand ils sont enserrés
dans un soutien gorge il ya une enquête
alors il n'y a pas beaucoup mais il ya
une enquête qui a montré que les saints
n'ont soutenu par un soutien-gorge
pouvait même se redresser un peu au
cours du temps en fait si les saints
s'affaisse c'est parce que en
vieillissant la peau change de nature
mais la peau de tout le corps elle
devient plus large plus souple et donc
forcément la peau étant moins tonique et
bien les seins ça fait simplement mais
ça fait partie d'un processus naturel
qui concerne toutes les femmes quel que
soit la taille de leur sein et quel que
soit aussi le fait qu'elle faisait
porter un soutien gorge ou pas
[Musique]
les injonctions sociale mais aussi
patriarcal laisse penser que les saints
row et gros sont beaux et sexy et que
seuls ses seins ronds un gros sont beaux
et sexy
c'est évidemment une illusion et c'est
surtout en fait une injonction pénible
pour les phares parce que les seins des
femmes sont très divers et que les
petits seins sont tout aussi beau que
les plus gros et qu'il y à des hommes et
des femmes qui aiment les petits seins
il ya des hommes et des femmes qui
aiment les seins ronds gros peu importe
il faut cesser de s'imaginer en quelque
sorte qu'il y aurait un corps idéal un
beau corps de femmes tous les corps de
femme son beau parce qu'il n'ya pas de
modèle uniforme et tous les saints des
femmes sont beaux